olá pessoal de quem fala é o dar que
seja muito bem vindo já mais um vídeo e
arroz traduzir a equipe fight night é
fredes strunck ciência e não pessoal
nunca em vídeo que vá ler os comentários
que vocês deixaram por lá e supostamente
tem mais duas finais por fazer e claro
pessoal claro que eu sabia que existia
mais gameplay que neste o cumprimento
que não podia ter só uma estrela em da
hipótese temos mais duas
e esses dois extremos de bukowski
contando miguel supostamente isso e
contando uma parte parece igual faz
nascer feliz 1 mil vai ser muito louco
pelo fascismo disseram lario tem que
concluir então está um minigame que vai
estar aqui na opção dos a strans
se não me engano é que eu já que houve
alguns vídeos portanto já sim sim mas
realmente que eu tenho que fazer é
basicamente está é que uma sister no
canto mas não só pela beleza e isso vai
ser complicado também porque por
supostamente temos que implementar todas
as crianças que têm uma rota específica
que eu tenho que fazer por cavalos bons
avalia os bulls têm ataques diferentes
portanto eu vou ter que fazer a rota que
o time já virou já tivemos que ficar um
pouco está porque senão ia ficar aqui
quatro horas outra vez e eu não quero
isso vamos lá o usuário que ninguém
pessoal e da gente só vejam só apostar
em nós temos a lei o tempo mas eu não
vou ligar muito agora porque eu só
queria treinar aqui em rota então o que
nós vamos ter que fazer é saltar aqui
pra apanhar este bolinho
até aqui tudo bem temos que aumentar
essa criança esta criança saltar aqui e
agora basta nós não vamos alimentar por
que não fazer isso mais pra frente
parlamentar estas duas
agora voltamos aqui a asaf gosta pra mim
é que o gol não era suas notas boas pra
cá eu vou tentar fazer campanha agora eu
vou tentar ao máximo fazer isso em
comprar aqui um pouquinho de tempo lá
lamenta este dois agora alimento este
movimento vai vai a não sair fazendo
gosta do mesmo a mostra já perdi muito
tempo aqui ok ela tem saltado em cima
isso aguça ricos que bobo foi só que
agora tem de alimentar a criança
o ajax gosta não não não não tem que ir
atrás de apanhar aqui o gozo que o bolso
é muito choque portanto eu consiga
acertar muito e os três ao mesmo tempo
até agora vai ver só eu vou tentar fazer
isso agora eu duvido que consiga porque
já passou um tempo aí agora saltamos
para saltar dispara exato agora vou ter
que ir em frente
apanhar aqui outro lá nenhum olha a
união calma vou saltar aqui caratinga e
isso agora não fiz boas e tinha que
saltar não eu fiz mostra feliz basta eu
tenho de saltar lpm tentar não apanhar
aqui o outro e isso aparece partida
complicada porque saltar aqui a fome a
boa consegui exatamente isso mesmo curso
que cai agora salto alimentos 3 deu deu
boa época e agora apanho este banho pra
trás
faltou aquelas crianças pode também
falar mais de trás tira isso nossa
certeza agora também para trás o trecho
eu caí
a exceção é complicado está complicado
isso isso vai só mas só agora é que tem
que saltar a urna o sol urina que eu só
fiquei um só tempo é difícil
ots o alcance da câmera ficou sem
bateria agora o [ __ ] esquecem de
susto
eu já tinha visto isso justo diz que sim
deu ok já tem de estrelas
será que já tem duas estrelas - vamos
ver do oeste elas lá há a meu eu tenho
aqui pra em 20 minutos ainda jogar em
estoque a quebrada e ficou sem bateria
mas consegui passar então aqui está
passando e ninguém e vamos lá pessoal
então para o verdadeiro não falso falso
fim a isso eu já passei pra dar
vamos pro falso fim e vocês me disseram
que eu tinha que ir pra noite cinco
supostamente né
eu acho que é isso aí pra noite 5 e
quando nós formos ram por aquela sala
escura nós temos que ir para a direita
em vez de ir para a esquerda eu acho que
eu vou passar isso para a frente à
espera do elevador ainda foi embora
muito a cápsula o jogador chegou é que o
golo de chegar ao destino e vamos lá ver
seu lado ainda não abro aqui o game vai
ficar aqui vamos lá ver se funciona
vamos ver se funciona comigo né
o instrumento eu vou entrar no projeto
ruim que é supostamente um antigo que
fornecem fred sun walk a terceira que é
bom vamos lá ver se o suposto momento
que vocês me tiraram funciona fazer com
que alguns que dão o tom do brasil mesmo
facto naturalizam se lia caiu
pessoal eu já vi alguns em outubro
chegará em achar esta partida ok se
apresentar assim ambientados a cujo
terceiro
eu já vi algo pessoal jogaria e
basicamente eu sei que tenho aqui por um
corre qualquer eu acho que a data da
é que em 1987
acho que esse é não milla 800
ai não 1983 é esse exatamente agora as
câmeras estão ligadas
este é aquele matronic pergunta e último
episódio qual será eletrônico ao de uma
iii esta que este animatronics rock
básico tem que fazer é fechar os portos
é só isso a hiperventilação que a
senhora tem uma inflação em cima a cair
a partir das crian ças jogar só por
jogar aqui eu não vou jogar a série b só
tentar ambientar-me que já com este
office é o quinto com 78% bateria uma da
manhã e obviamente que eu vou ter que
fazer isso muito mais rápido né
só tenho que tentar entender o esquema
agora já posso abrir lançamentos acima
da câmera 2 exatamente esse é o esquema
então eu vou ter que ficar mais atento a
câmera 5 a câmera 11 ea câmera 2 porque
devem tê lo sair das duas portas
pelo que eu ouvi as dicas do pessoal
tudo já que já passou esta noite o que
nos dizem é que supostamente para nós
comparamos mais bateria temos que ouvir
e ficar mais atentos ao som do próprio e
mental de imagens como podem ver já tá
aqui um gajo já que o único telefone já
está aqui nos ataque o palhaço e temos
que manter aquele aberto fechado à chave
agora só quando síria é que abrimos a
porta caiu já sei eu
agora vamos ver esta câmera e esta não
cair agora só pra essas próximas
olha que o feriu
aqui está tudo bem eu acho que é
essencialmente só temos que controlar
estes dois câmeras
estas três câmeras ou e as três câmeras
internas 3 canarinhos para controlar um
palhaço sol e ouvir já o som da esquerda
mas eu não tava que já na porta certo
não está já na porta ataque mais para
trás ou não é exato quando faz o
primeiro então pra lá mas também não
faço aqui um barulho faz aqui outubro e
fazem outro barulho portanto quando eu
fizer o psi em julho
quero dizer que nós podemos fechar a
porta temos devemos fechar a porta
é isso essa o um embrulho isso quer
dizer que o tac ou não não ele ainda
está lá atrás eu caí fez o tribunal está
a arranjar aqui [ __ ] tem que fechar a
porta não está mesmo a porta ainda vai
que não se importa eu estava mesmo na
porta e dizer por semana passado e não
está havendo agora aqui ok não está em
lado a pressão os pratos estão lá em
cima está lá em cima não quiseram
próximo julho está mais perto do norte e
achamos que puxaram exatamente isso já
percebi já possui técnica e preço
jacques vê o casal foi embora e fez
outro barulho exato é isso eu vou ter
que pensar neste jogo só com o som é só
essa técnica é só essa técnica é só o
som vai agora ficar o tempo está na
esquerda mas não está na porta ainda não
está na porta ainda não está na porta
vamos falar um pouco mais esperar até
fazer o seguro já fica próximo ao olho
para estar na porta ainda não sei lá
dentro
a fazer mais barulho eu até lá em cima
está lá em cima
vamos ficar atentos no próximo ano chama
de que a ventilação colchão na porta
exatamente
é isso mesmo agora no próximo livro de
ventilação é está está é só isso é só o
barulho e vejam só que brincar e brincar
eu já cheguei até às três da manhã nesta
porta daqui agora esperamos o próximo
filho
chap chap na hora local eu ligo não
agora eu também quer agora fala ai ai
calma esperar o próximo livro com muita
calma com muita calma assim é este faz
alguma coisa
a esquerda não está na esquerda sustenta
[ __ ] de contratar aqui do lado
acho que ela acha que ela não cair agora
espera o próximo julho e fechamos a
porta
chap chap ataque não foi tão fácil
não faço ideia que foi já já prevista
é só pra mim alto nas quatro da manhã e
buscar estatura
op esquerda a stock car ó eu estava na
porta eu estava na porta
agora é só pra já saiu
temos de abrir o botafago iraheta meu eu
acho que não vou conseguir passar esta
noite agora eu acho que sim
para o próximo ano e não ainda não só
quando ficar à porta
só quando ficar à porta chá não está
aqui eu não está aqui está então
desapareceu há que encarar faixa meu
deus eu estava aqui sim eu estava com as
apanhar o falta deste por cento desde o
princípio teria são quatro da manhã é
provável que não consiga passar se
começar agora seria desde o início mas
vou conseguir ganhar só tá quente para o
próximo futuro próximo não vai ainda
acho que os que também está na porta e
só foi embora 4% ganharam autonomia
alargada às suas praias pra eu não
pensei que você agora calma calma calma
o pessoal vamos falar agora está sério
eu vou já fazer estes pastores desde o
início já fica muito atento ao barulho e
tentar para o máximo bateria jadson o
início e vamos conseguir eu sei que
vamos conseguir
bora bora bora bora canto na direita
cinco da manhã e só faltou uma hora
[ __ ]
o tamanho do seu perfil la plata já na
esquerda
calma calma calma são simples aguentar a
rua estava a enganar [ __ ] acho que
não conseguiu se adaptar em cima tá em
cima em cima e fez gostar muito e
bateria
a água estava tão foco
faltava então por que lança muito rápido
meu deus faltava muito pouco à medida
que o tempo passa vai pensando mais em
jogar e eu vai ficando mais rápido e
efetivo é que ela lança injusta sabem
aquela balancinho injusta da [ __ ] não
gostava 30 teria um dia foi abaixo
o vasco aço ao tamanho muito casa muito
claro
ai coxim com os que conseguirem gols e
enjoy são time turno em goiás vovô
carlyle china que muito tempo eu acho
complicado jogar sozinho no botão de que
o fragmento felizes pelo que acham que
eu acho que anda comendo pipoca a
hitwise é agora bem pouquinho é se você
vai passando e e pipoca era bem o que é
isso
lima tony que está agora a tentar uma
história né eu não sei se chama sempre
não entra não [ __ ] aí supostamente já
conquistei o jogo é trair o ver estrelas
envolvendo as tramas [ __ ] três
estrelas pessoal a aati book o
personagem eu vou vir aqui embora só é
aquele metrô nicks é este é um é menor
diz o personagem animatrônico não estava
a tentar a história agora e ganhamos
esta coisa suposta isto é novo é que a
senhora que powers ex big brothers
powers é manteigas de exóticas manteiga
e só ficar juntos ganharam há como
manter que só fica é isso só vou ficar
porque foi o trabalho de ver o meu café
0 e é slash favorito fique bem tem um
dia maravilhoso mas quando é maravilhosa
e até já há quem joga até amanhã eu só
vou por vídeo a mãe agora eh eh